[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to a
special edition of ask Evan today we're
going to look at what is the role of the
balance sheet and how can we use it to
make important decisions for your
business into a recently ran a survey
which found that the single biggest
reason that most small businesses don't
succeed is that they lack the financial
literacy skills to navigate the
obstacles in front of them only 51
percent of companies that start up today
will still be around five years from now
in order to change that we're creating a
new series of posts on financial
literacy to help you make sense of the
information in front of you today we're
gonna look at what the role the balance
sheet is and how it can be used to help
you grow your business what is the role
of the balance sheet at a very high
level the balance sheet represents what
resources your company owns the assets
versus how much you owe to others your
liabilities the difference is your
owner's equity in the company let's
start with the assets using my
QuickBooks Online account I'm gonna
check out a sample balance sheet for you
to have a look at this is data from a
sample company Craig's designed and
landscaping services the assets are
split in the current assets and fixed
assets current assets are cash and
things that can be converted into cash
in a relatively short amount of time in
Craig's case he has a few bank accounts
accounts receivable and some undeposited
funds fixed assets are permanent
investments that are used to run the
business but are not actually for sale
by the business in Craig's cases only
fixed asset is this truck but it can
also include equipment buildings lands
patents and so on now let's look at
Craig's liabilities and owner's equity
liabilities are split in the current
liabilities and long-term liabilities
current liabilities are what your
company owes it has to pay off within a
year from the balance sheet being
created in Craig's case he has accounts
payable credit cards loans and sales tax
to pay long-term liabilities or
everything else at your company owes
that is due beyond one year for the
balance sheet being created in Craig's
case his only long-term liability is a
note payable now a balance sheet has to
well balance so the difference between
your assets and your liabilities is your
equity
if we look at cranks complete balance
sheet you'll see that he has thirty
thousand two hundred seventy-five
dollars in liabilities and only twenty
six thousand six hundred and eighty four
dollars in assets which gives him a
negative equity of three thousand five
hundred and ninety dollars so how does
this help none of you know what the
numbers mean and their values you can
start making important business
decisions from them here are a few to
consider number one current assets two
current liabilities also known as
working capital you want to have more
current assets compared to current
liabilities this will help ensure that
you have enough money to find your
short-term debts as well as the
day-to-day operations of your business
if your current liabilities are more
than your current assets then you're
going to feel a major cash crunch within
the next year your options could be to
make more sales sell some inventory
restructure your loans or apply for
short-term financing if we look at
Craigs data
he has thirteen thousand two hundred and
thirty nine dollars in current assets
and only five thousand two hundred
seventy five in current liabilities so
right now he doesn't have to worry
number two fixed assets two long-term
liabilities you also want to have more
fixed assets than log through
liabilities this will help ensure that
you have enough in the business to fund
your longer term debts ideally you want
your long-term liabilities to be around
fifty to seventy percent of your fixed
assets if your ratio is higher remember
that the value of fixed assets like land
buildings patents and so on often
increase with time and your best bet
would be to try and refinance and pitch
your lender that it's better to have
them keep you around and making payments
rather than force you into liquidity
look in a Craigs data we see he's in
trouble
his fixed assets total thirteen thousand
four hundred and forty five and his
long-term liabilities are twenty five
thousand dollars this means that if he
can't turn his business around he's
going to be in serious cash crunch after
the year is up
number three raising capital finally
let's look at the story about she chose
the potential investors if you want to
raise money any investor or lender will
want to see your balance sheet they're
going to look at your working capital
see if you can survive in a short run
and they'll compare your fixed assets to
your long-term liabilities to see if you
can survive in the long run but they're
also going to look at your equity they
want to see how much you have in the
business if you don't have much equity
it's going to make it hard for them to
give you any kind of money because
you're very high risk looking at Craigs
data again he's in trouble he has
negative equity of three thousand five
hundred and ninety dollars
he took out a twenty five thousand
dollar loan and spent thirteen thousand
and a half approximately on a truck
where did the other eleven thousand five
hundred dollars go while Craig's company
has some positive signs in that it has
over three thousand dollars in net
income which means the company earned
more in revenue than it spent in
expenses it would be very hard for Craig
to convince someone to give him more
money without proving he can do better
or providing a personal guarantee to
wrap up it all starts with the tools 76%
of entrepreneurs who use financial
software or solution or accountant
provided feel confident that they have a
strong grasp of financial management
principles if you know where the
problems are ahead of time you can plan
for them so you're not constantly
putting out fires as they happen here's
your next step starting the business can
be empowering but it also demands a
level financial understanding to make
sure your business succeeds to help
address this need of financial expertise
into it is offering free one-on-one
consultation for small businesses with
their Intuit pro advisers entrepreneurs
can go to WWF raw or calm / Intuit
Canada to set up a free consultation
today thank you for joining me for
another edition of ask Evan if you like
this video you want to see more please
give it a thumbs up below what makes me
want to do more of these videos for you
guys I'd also love to hear what you have
to think if you want to leave a comment
under the video I always read those and
I love seeing them come in so thank you
I will see you on the next episode
[Music]